votre soirée spéciale élections
régionales se poursuit en bourgogne et
franche comté avec le résultat définitif
nous allons vous le rappeler dans un
instant au dos avant cela je vous
présente les trois invités qui nous ont
rejoints sur le plateau marie-guite
dufay donc tête de liste du parti
socialiste qui arrive donc en tête de ce
scrutin vos côtés à nathalie vermorel
qui était tête de liste pour alternative
à gauche et françois de sales vous êtes
le patron du modem pour la bourgogne
merci à tous les troncs va redonner tout
de suite les résultats définitifs
résultats définitifs sur en bourgogne et
franche-comté où la liste de marie guite
dufay ps prg arrive donc en tête avec 34
7% des voix devant celle de françois
sauvadet et l'air udi avec 32,9 % et le
front national arrive troisième essai
serré avec 32,4 pour cent ce qui
donnerait en répartition des sièges sur
les 100 sièges du futur conseil régional
de bourgogne et de franche-comté 51 élus
pour marie-guite dufay la liste ps prg
25 pour la droite et 24 pour le front
national
je vous propose à présent tu d'écouté et
bien les premières réactions à ces
résultats on va aller dans le jura dans
la ville de lons le saunier qui a placé
la liste socialiste en tête ce soir des
réactions recueillies pour nous par
vanessa hirson et récupérer
dans ce bar la télévision tournent en
boucle sur une chaîne musicale
mais ce soir au vu des résultats
définitifs c'est le front national qui
déchantent en tête au premier tour dans
le jura grande perdante au second pour
certaines personnes rencontrées ce soir
c'est la loi de la démocratie
on reste sur quelque chose de très très
simple une majorité aujourd'hui s'est
exprimé à ce que je sais pas les
résultats exacts qu'elle s'attache à ce
cas mais il ya des gens qui seront déçus
certainement il ya des gens qui seront
satisfaits dans ce restaurant au coeur
de lons le saunier ses amis sont
satisfaits des résultats et ils le font
savoir
moi j'en suis contente et le fait que le
front national soit battu dans toutes
les régions de france
rabat - j'en suis ravi et soulagé
et le fait que ce soit mardi du fait du
coût qui prennent la direction de la
région faut c'est bien parce qu'il avait
un résultat positif
la région moi je trouve que c'est vous
c'est positif pour la région ça reste
des voix là c'est très bien parce que
moi je suis pas du tout front national
par contre maintenant va falloir qu'elle
fasse ses preuves madame du feu
marie-guite dufay est arrivé en tête
dans le jura avec 36 points 11 % des
voix nous poserons la question mérite du
fai parole des lecteurs parole de
twitter également elsa petite réaction
un petit tweet de christian paul donc lé
député socialiste de la nièvre qui écrit
ce soir il ya sept minutes précisément
après ce sursaut citoyen ne revenons pas
la politique de l'autruche retrouvons
idéaux efficacité vite un nouvel agenda
démocratique qu'est ce que seraient nos
invités demain dans notre émission
spéciale à à 12h55 sur france 3 au dos
marie-guite dufay une question forcément
vous l'avez entendu l'arrivée du fed
doit faire ses preuves
ce que vous sentez aujourd'hui afin
cette victoire avec ses ça s'est joué à
peu de voix finalement un peu de choses
est ce que vous sentez qui effectivement
va falloir faire vos preuves
écoutez je suis heureuse de cette
victoire mais j'ai le sentiment vous
savez d'une victoire responsable je me
sens une immense responsabilité parce
que j'ai senti combien les fractures
était grande dans notre pays je vois
combien le vote front national recèle
d'inquiétude inquiétudes légitimes par
rapport aux difficultés économiques par
rapport au chômage mais aussi combien il
recèle de défiance de défiance par
rapport à la vie politique par rapport
au parti par rapport à tous les partis
traditionnels dont dont le bien
j'en ai absolument conscience et c'est
pour cela que j'ai conscience d'une
grande responsabilité
on entend on entend cela depuis 2000
2 notamment et même avant depuis que le
front national alain progresse mais
qu'est ce qu'il va faire en sorte que
vous vous pourriez changer cette
situation en tant que présidente de
région et d'une grande région désormais
écouter ce sont toutes les régions qui
travaillent ensemble qu'ils doivent
absolument expérimenté sur la question
numéro un du chômage qui doivent
expérimenter des dispositifs d'aidé
méthodes et moi je pense que nous avons
avec la formation qui notre grande
compétence
un levier pour amener de la protection à
protection aussi bien pour les salariés
dans des entreprises qui sont
confrontées à des difficultés que pour
les demandeurs d'emploi c'est ce que
j'appelle la sécurité professionnelle je
les dis pendant tout tout le tout ma
campagne j'ai axé ma campagne là dessus
nous avons créé la sécurité sociale en
1945 ce sont nos ancêtres
au sortir de la guerre qu'ils ont voulu
je pense que la gauche aujourd'hui doit
créer une sécurité professionnelle par
la formation notamment
et c'est d'un travail auquel je m'attèle
depuis longtemps déjà
en franche comté en travaillant avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux et je
veut amplifier ce travail ce soir marié
du fait vous gagnez principalement grâce
aux villes de la région vous êtes en
tête dans quasiment toutes les villes
même des villes de droite comme lons le
saunier où chalon sur saône on en a
parlé tout à l'heure ça veut dire aussi
que les campagnes aujourd'hui sont
acquises à la droite ou à l'extrême
droite
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire pour
peut-être endiguer le sentiment
d'abandon qui peut y avoir dans le monde
rural aujourd'hui
écoutez j'ai élaboré 122 propositions je
pense que vous les avez lu la 110e je
crois qu'avec 110 propositions j'en ai
tous de plus
mais nous pour presque il ya une
opposition claire ville-campagne ce soir
il y a un sentiment d'abandon dans les
campagnes kiki qui repose sur des choses
qui sont vraies qui sont réelles sur
d'autres qui le sont moins et il faut
absolument que nous renforcions nos
politiques il doit il doit pas y avoir
de de distance entre la ville et la
campagne et tout le rôle d'une région
comme la bourgogne franche comté qui est
une région forte de ses campagnes comme
de seville s'est trouvé le bon équilibre
et donc ça ça s'appelle la politique
d'aménagement du territoire
ça veut dire travailler à conforter les
services des services publics en milieu
rural
les maisons de santé pour qu'il y ait
une véritable égalité d'accès aux soins
pour tout le monde ça veut dire être
dans l' écoute aussi et je pense que l'
écoute la participation des citoyens à
l'élaboration de nos politiques c'est un
vaste chantier qu'il faut ouvrir très
vite c'est-à-dire vous reconnaissez que
vous avez péché vous au sens large à
vous les politiques vous la région le
gouvernement aussi peut-être vous avez
péché là dessus aujourd'hui jusqu'à
présent en tout cas je ne suis pas sûr
que les régions et plus pêcher que
d'autres niveaux de collectivités mais
je pense que globalement les citoyens ne
se sentent pas assez concernés par la
chose publique et que le divorce entre
les citoyens et la chose publique est
une chose grave et qu'il faut y remédier
et que peut-être une première façon d'y
remédier c'est de voir comment on fait
davantage participer les citoyens très
en amont à l'élaboration de nos
politiques une autre chose c'est aussi
de tenir nos engagements et c'est pour
ça que j'étais très fier de voir combien
la franche-comté été félicités pour
avoir tenu ses engagements par rapport à
nos promesses de campagne de 2010 c'est
le monde qui a dit que vous étiez la wii
vers seule la présidente qui allait le
plus respecté c mais oui mais c'est
capital c'est capital
faire ce que l'on a dit je pense que
c'est très important pour retrouver le
chemin de la confiance et cette
confiance
elle est beaucoup trop et rodez il faut
vraiment là travailler à régler chez
vous on va rester avec vous vous avez
été suivi dans cette journée un peu
particulière forcément notamment avec
ses résultats
une équipe vous a suivi tout au long de
la journée et je propose justement de
découvrir leurs reportages aller une
bénigne ski david martin c'est loin des
caméras et des micros que marc guide du
fai a choisi de découvrir les résultats
la socialiste a attendu d'être sûre pour
arriver en préfecture est accompagné des
candidats écologistes et communistes
c'est la victoire de turquie qui m'ont
fait confiance
c'est une victoire chèrement acquise
j'ai conscience de l'immense
responsabilité qui est la mienne et j'ai
conscience aussi que beaucoup de voix
sont allées sur mon nom est sur ma liste
pour faire échec et barrage au front
national et que beaucoup beaucoup de
choses sont à reconstruire son nez
absolument consiste à sailly de
questions des le perron est félicité de
toutes parts après l'arrivée photo radio
télé la nouvelle présidente de la
bourgogne franche comté n'a pas le temps
de souffler la journée a été longue et
elle n'est pas terminée
c'est surtout le soir en fin de journée
que c'est un peu stressant mais
autrement
j'ai pris les moyens de faire des choses
que je peux pas faire habituelle
habituellement je suis allée marchait il
ya un plateau télé parce qu'après je
voudrais retrouver des militants bien
entendu puis tous ceux qui m'ont aidé
très fortement pendant cette campagne
mais
le soulagement est là encore quelques
embrassades et quelques bravo à peine le
temps de se restaurer et vite
il faut filer à la télé et nous vous
avons vu marié du ch au côté de cécile
prud'hommes qui était tête de liste
europe écologie les verts je vous
propose d'écouter faire action presse au
deuxième tour soulagé parce que la
région reste à gauche inquiète parce que
le taux d'abstentionnistes du premier
tour et une réelle inquiétude le fait
d'être d'avoir une mobilisation maximum
et que quand on est face au fn ça
m'inquiète parce que ça veut dire que
les gens croient plus en la politique et
que la politique doit se remettre en
question réellement et je pense que on a
une urgence démocratique
surtout que les présidentielles sont pas
loin quoi donc voilà pour ça que je suis
effectivement soulagé que la région
reste à gauche est très inquiète sur
l'état
la pole et de la politique nationale
quoi nathalie vermorel est avec nous sur
le plateau de la tête de liste
d'alternative à gauche il n'y aura pas
d'élus de votre liste dans le prochain
conseil régional est-ce que quel est
votre sentiment ce soir vous êtes
soulagés vous êtes déçu de ne pas
participer justement à cette nouvelle
grande région vous faites les les
questions et les réponses effectivement
soulagé parce qu'effectivement un de nos
objectifs et nous l'avions annoncé très
clairement dans notre liste était de ne
pas permettre que la droite ou l'extrême
droite puisse s'emparer de cette région
déçu de ne pas y participer parce que
effectivement je pense que dans la
précédente assemblée en tout cas en
bourgogne nous étions présents nous
avons apporté notre touche particulière
d'une gauche qui ne renonce pas à ses
valeurs d'une gauche proche des
populations proches des syndicalistes
proche des associations qui a fait
valoir un certain nombre de politiques
et elles ne seront plus portés au
conseil régional dont vous allez appeler
oui et pour marine et du fait que vous
avez passé une sorte d'accord quelles
garanties finalement vous vous avez ce
soir que marie-guite dufay mène une
politique qui vous conviennent j'adhère
face au front national on marchande pas
c'est la première des choses moi je suis
suivie d'un parti qui s'appelait parti
des fusillés à l'issue de la guerre
parce que en saône et loire par exemple
nous n'avions plus aucun membre du parti
communiste vivant ap la guerre parce
qu'ils s'étaient tous engagés jusqu'au
prix de leur vie pour lutter contre le
fascisme
je n'ai pas oublié sa sas marchombres ça
c'est l'histoire
aujourd'hui il était impératif que l'ex
endroit qu'on ne prenne pas cette région
marie-guite dufay a dit et hardy très
clairement y compris sur le perron de la
préfecture
quelles sont engagés à trouver les
moyens de travailler avec nous allons
dans la semaine qui vient donner quinze
jours à venir prendre rendez-vous et
voir ensemble de quelle manière pourra
se concrétiser ce travail commun mais
j'avais conçu beaucoup d'ambitions j'ai
beaucoup d'idées sur ce que nous
pourrions faire ensemble nous avons dans
la lys l'alternative à gauche porter des
projets des propositions très concrètes
dont nous allons voir maintenant après
coup je n'ai aucune garantie je n'ai que
sa parole que nous allons voir à l'aune
des actes si cette parole est sincère
authentique et elle est là ce soir pour
nous dire c'est le
alors votre parole marie-guite dufay que
vaut-elle c'est l'avenir qui le dira il
ya une union de la gauche c'est en
quelque sorte dans les urnes ce soir est
ce que vous regrettez qu'elle ne se
traduise pas dans le futur exécutif
absolument absolument ce fut le grand
regret de du premier tour je l'avais
d'ailleurs pressenti quand j'avais su
qu'au niveau national il y avait une
position pour effectivement que chacun
parte de son côté
oui c'est un grand regret ça vous donne
des obligations vous avez l'impression
d'avoir été lui aussi contre le front
national plutôt que pour vous peut-être
non non il faut quand même pas exagérer
un mois j'ai quand même le sentiment
depuis ce soir qu'effectivement c'est
tout ceci je suis gagner en taille
exagérons pas reprendre avec c'est vrai
que parfois ça s'enchaîne mais
finalement c'est pas une victoire
finalement des obligations des
responsabilités j'ai dit que c'était une
une victoire que je sens avec une grande
grande force de responsabilité oui de
toute façon moi je pense que seule la
gauche une gauche qui se retrouvent est
une gauche digne de ce nom et une gauche
qui se retrouvent elles et avec toutes
ses composantes
ces composantes communiste ses
composantes écologistes composantes
citoyenne composantes démocratiques et
donc c'est cela aussi l'intérêt de de la
gauche un tout petit monde nathalie
vermorel c'est à dire que ce tripartisme
qui a été largement développée est voulu
y compris par le président de la
république sont totalement contre
productif on le voit aujourd'hui à force
de n'avoir que trois forces en lice et
bien il y en a au moins deux qui manque
dans le futur exécutif régional
moi j'invite à plus de démocratie et à
aller sur ces sujets pose il voterait
une seule envie de vous entendre avant
dès le premier tour alors la
responsabilité c'est celui qui est le
plus fort qui ont créé les conditions en
aujourd'hui parti socialiste et au
moment où on en a parlé ne crée pas les
conditions d'une union de la gauche il a
créé tout simplement développement des
politiques de droite
evo naissent ainsi profiter du
mécontentement vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
s'agit jamais de profiter d'un
mécontentement il s'agit de porter une
parole et de porter des propositions
qu'ils rencontrent à ce moment là une
perspective politique et une attente des
populations
on n'est pas dans un marchandage dans
ces moments là françois deseille vous et
eux aussi avec nous vous êtes satisfait
vous ce soir je dois vous aviez appelé
sans appuyer tout en appelant à voter
pour marine du fait j'ai appelé à voter
pour la liste qui me paraissait la plus
à même de faire barrage au front
national
c'était un acte républicain j'ai dit ça
avait été une autre liste j'aurais sans
état d'âme appelé cet autre liste à
voter pour cette autre vie cela c'était
en l'occurrence sa liste de marie-guite
dufay et je le regrette pas
les résultats montrent que 20 ans
j'avais eu raison euro avait fait
d'autres choix ils avaient appelé les
partisans du système de dire que le
troisième devait se retirer
il n'était pas forcément au courant de
ce qui se passait sur la bourgogne
franche comté à paris jean peut-être
internet à tous qu'ils auraient
peut-être dû c'est vrai tout cas c'était
comme ça il aurait lui d'huile estimé
que dans un acte républicain
les troisièmes devait se retirer mais
c'est vrai que là je peux comprendre
qu'avec un score aussi serré et un
réservoir de votes plus important pour
la liste de gauche d'ailleurs ça qui m'a
fait plonger de ce côté là pour sauver
pour moi je voulais absolument pas que
la bourgogne franche comté passe au
niveau du front national et je me
félicite madame mobilisation j'ai tenu
un bureau de vote toute la journée et
j'ai vu énormément de jeunes et ça ça
m'a vraiment fait plaisir qu'ils sont
venus et je pense sont des jeunes qui
ont voté pour les partis républicains la
droite la gauche peu importe au total
ils ont voté pour la république
ils ont voulu faire barrage au front
national et ça c'est très important mais
vous dit tout à l'heure vous avez parlé
d'une victoire responsable mais c'est
vraiment très important p6 a quand même
n'oublions pas le score du front
national n'oublions pas le premier tour
qui aurait plutôt que ça allait se
passer comme ça au deuxième tour
tant mieux ça s'est bien passé mais il y
aura peut-être attention à la prochaine
élection si on écoute pas ces gens si on
n'écoute pas les 30 % d'électeurs qui
disent attention on va pas bien c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux bourgogne franche
comté mais attend d'eux sans compter une
bourgogne franche comté urbaine une voie
en franche comté rural et les deux
salles à la ruralité souffre il faut les
écouter
je compte sur vous un je compte sur le
pouvoir enfin la président nouvelle
présidente pour pouvoir
vraiment répondre à ces questions sinon
la prochaine fois ça va être terrible je
veux éviter ça après pour moi je pense
que c'est vrai que l'union était bien
j'ai toujours prôné l'union des partis
l'union une gouvernance le partage avec
qui mais le modem on n'y comprend plus
rien vous avez proposé à muse avait un
sourire un exécutif de gauche à dijon en
l'occurrence l'amérique disions pas dit
je mange france comté est associé à des
exécutifs de droite ne m'a pas vraiment
bornes sans associer que des effectifs
de droite quand ce nous sommes au niveau
municipal et quelle est la lisibilité
mais la lisibilité au niveau municipal
c'est l'intérêt général qui prône avant
tout d'accords pour nous il n'y a pas de
clivage gauche droite et dans les autres
collectivités non c'est pas l'intérêt
pour espionnage aurait aimé françois
sauvadet deuxième propose à marie-guite
dufay de s'associer et travailler pour
faire barrage c'était pour moi le plus
grand barrage qui puisse exister au
niveau du foot par rapport au front
national il l'a pas fait bon il a perdu
2 voilà s'est posée pour le temps pour
lui dire maintenant c'est marie-guite
dufay qui m'apparaissait le meilleur
barrage au front national
vis-à-vis dans un cadre de deux trois
partis au deuxième tour mais je veux
dire l'union aurait été peut-être
sympathique et on quand on voit que les
scores sont si serrés pourquoi pas
travailler ensemble mais vous restez
modèle ce soir même si justes réalistes
que vous en 16 ans sa première fois que
je ne suis pas d'accord je veux dire
mais je ne regrette pas mon choix
étant donné que sam hamad les résultats
ont donné raison et tant mieux jeudi le
mérite du fait gagner les partis
républicains ont gagné
j'en ai fait barrage au front national
points maintenant attention parce qu'on
n'aura pas le droit à l'erreur il
faisons tous dansé une grande
responsabilité qui lui incombe à celle
attendue au cas du front national juste
après un coup d'oeil sur twitter elsawy
juste pour rebondir ce qui a été dit ces
dernières minutes et notamment avec vous
madame du fait ce tweet de guerre abou
zian député socialiste de côte-d'or et
qui écrit vous le voyez cette difficile
victoire nous oblige le front national
obtient 32,4 pour cent des voix et donc
24 sièges au futur conseil régional
déception dans l'yonne où le fn arrive
cela dit en tête les militants espèrent
la victoire de sophie montel paroles de
militants ambiance au qg du front
national de l'yonne avec rémy chidaine
et tanya gomez 20 heures ou dit mme
bardot serre
pour les militants réunis ici le verdict
tombe la liste front national n'arrive
qu'en troisième position en bourgogne
franche comté
bien sûr il ya une déception une
déception de ne pas pas de ne pas avoir
pu gagner cette région
énormément de français l'attendaient à
les voir à l'oeuvre
nous serons des des opposants acharnés
des visages fermés les regrets sont à la
hauteur de l'espoir qui habitait les
militants de l'yonne au premier tour
sophie montel avait recueilli plus de
36% des voix dans le département en tête
avec près de 14 points d'avance sur la
liste de droite et un peu plus tôt dans
la soirée les premiers résultats locaux
laissés vivre l'optimisme qu'on va
attendre sereinement les résultats qui
nous arrivent petit à petit donc on a
des résultats qui sont plutôt plutôt
positif
l'yonne n'est qu'un département delà de
la grande région donc la victoire ne
dépend pas que de nous le vote régional
n'a donc pas suivi les premières
tendances icaunaise mais tout le monde
ne veut pas se laisser abattre
le front national sera bien représenté
dans le nouveau conseil régional où
chacun aura son mot à dire et c'est une
évolution favorable pour une nouvelle
région et demain sera une nouvelle
bataille
et cette nouvelle bataille permettra
peut-être un jour d'arriver à quelque
chose de plus concluants et donner
peut-être une force de gouvernance sur
une région au front national
reste que ce scrutin laissera pour les
frontistes de l'yonne un goût amer celui
d'un essai attendu mais finalement non
transformé un essai non transformé pour
le front national jérémy mais qui
néanmoins explose ce que vous avez
appelé tout à l'heure son plafond de
verre c'est à dire son nombre de voix en
termes de suffrages
attention attention aux analyses
chiffré par pourcentage parce que il
faut se méfier des faux semblants le si
on prend le nombre de bulletins fn au
premier tour 303000 ce soir le fn à
rassemble plus de 370 mille bulletins
370 mille votants et c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus par exemple que le
meilleur score jamais atteint en
bourgogne franche comté par un candidat
front national en l'occurrence marine le
pen au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle 2012 qui avait rassemblé
3 130 mille voix c'était déjà beaucoup
mais dans un contexte de participation
beaucoup plus massive
donc la plus de 370 mille voix le front
national a explosé son plafond de verre
aujourd'hui en ce deuxième tour des
régionales en bourgogne franche comté
merci beaucoup jérémy et le front
national qui aura donc 24 sièges dans la
future assemblée et bien parmi les
nouveaux conseillers régionaux sophie
montel la tête de liste du front
national ont rejoint tout de suite et
qui est aux côtés de catherine m séries
dans les studios de besançon et oui
trois invités avec nous sur le plateau à
besançon tout d'abord martial bourquin
qui est maire d'audincourt et sénateurs
socialistes face à lui annie genevard
député maire de morteau lr c'est une
ancienne conseillère régionale et puis
comme vous le disiez sophie montel tête
de liste régionale pour le front
national vous êtes élu au conseil
régional de franche comté depuis 1998
deux habitants sur trois de bourgogne
franche comté n'ont pas voulu de vous ce
soir
est-ce que tout à l'heure vous vous
entendez vous disiez que c'était
pratiquement une victoire vous allez un
peu vite en besogne
en tout cas c'est une victoire à la
pyrrhus pour mes adversaires parce que
vous l'avez noté jérémy cheuvreux il a
rappelé
à l'instant le front national a très
très largement progressé lors de ce
deuxième tour de cette élection
régionale et je note madame syrie que
tout se joue dans un mouchoir de poche
il ya eu certes une sur mobilisation des
électeurs de gauche mais les électeurs
du front national
visiblement il ya une sur mobilisation
des gens qui ne veulent pas d'une
présidente front national à la tête de
bourgogne franche comté je note que nous
avons progressé dans l'entre-deux tours
et si nous n'avions pas eu cette
campagne de haine dans l'entre-deux
tours où le temps le premier ministre
que les présidents d'université et que
les syndicats que les présidents
d'associations que les uns et les autres
en fait tous ceux qui vivent du système
si tous ces gens là ne s'étaient pas
mobilisés contre le front national et
avait laisser le peuple choisir en toute
connaissance de cause je pense que les
résultats auraient été bien différent ce
soir moi ce que je note ce que nous
sommes nous portons la dynamique nous ne
sommes pas très loin de la liste
conduite par lui dit sauvadet
pour preuve le front national aura 24
élus udi heller 25 au sein du nouveau
conseil régional bourgogne franche comté
donc ce soir voilà je suis déçu
évidemment parce que nous n'avons pas
gagné la région bourgogne franche comté
mais en même temps je suis plein
d'espoir et je me dis que voilà c'est
pas passé bien loin
annie genevard s'est pas passé bien loin
pour le front national s'est pas passé
bien loin pour nous non plus
ce soir moi j'ai un double sentiment
d'abord évidemment une grande déception
c'est une défaite pour pour la droite et
le centre même si c'est une défaite de
peu et je trouve que elle est d'autant
plus amère que la liste que conduisait
françois sauvadet patrick genre dans le
doubs était une liste de grande qualité
des gens qui n'ont pas démérité qui ont
de l'expérience qu'ils ont qui enlevait
expliqué lauréats granger et bien je
l'expliquent c'est mécanique une fois de
plus comme en 2004
comme en 2010 puisque ces deux campagnes
là je les avais fait là je n'étais pas
candidate mais c'est le même scénario
qui se reproduit le fn front national se
confirme comme l'allié objectif du parti
socialiste puisque d'ailleurs j'ai sali
dans les urgences
d'ailleurs quand vous parlez d'aller
objectif que donc vous avise est assez
lent de façon à ce que sophie montel et
martial bourquin soit côte à côte parce
que vous voulez représenter physiquement
cette alliance objective
vous n'avez pas un petit peu loin quand
même non c'est mécanique je vais vous
donner un exemple dans ma ville à mort
tout est bien le front national fait dix
points de moins qu'au niveau régional et
nous faisons par conséquent 10 points de
plus enfin je veux dire
tous les analystes politiques ça veut
dire qu'il ya une saoudite et sa bien
aimée mais à vis du front national en
par ces sables voulais l'aider à mai
mais aussi à gauche et marchette
bourquin le sait bien
le front national est le réceptacle des
lecteurs qui veulent le front national
mais qui auront la gauche pendant 16 ans
martial bourquin front national allié
objectif du parti socialiste sur sérieux
nous a donné raison en 2004 et en 2006
vous avez gagné la région également dans
des triangulaires avec le front national
obtient une triangulaire il ya trois
candidats et on est installé durablement
dans le tripartisme c'est les électeurs
qui l'ont choisi je suis très heureux
que marie-guite dufay soit élu avec sa
liste
en même temps je n'oublie pas le premier
tour y compris yahoo dako audincourt où
il ya eu un front national beaucoup trop
mal à montels a parlé d'une campagne de
haine c'est un parti de haine qui dresse
les français les uns contre les autres
qui a des solutions qui ne sont pas des
solutions qui mettrait l'économie
complètement dans le cas où un mail à
ses dons attendez attendez j'ai essayé
de répondre dans une ville comme monaco
par exemple monsieur sauvadet ou premier
tour fait plus que 11 % des voix il se
fait siphonné par le front national
donc il y à une porosité beaucoup plus
grande
comme vous le disiez tout de suite entre
la droite et le front national des
électeurs de droite choisit de voter
front national il y a eu aussi des
électeurs de gauche qui sont si elle est
souvent un cheval blé lââm est
aujourd'hui là pour marie-guite dufay
cette victoire c'est parce que il y
avait en face un front national dont
personne ne voulait elle semblait être
en mesure de l'emporter
c'est ça c'est le chiffon front national
est agité par le camp de gauche pour
mobiliser le temps de gauche c'est plus
un vote d'adhésion au parti socialiste
c'est un vote de rejet du front national
je pense que vous allez un peu vite sur
le bilan de marie-guite dufay le bilan
françois patriat
il y a eu un sondage qui disait que
c'était certainement les régions les
mieux gérées de france ça c'est la
première des choses
faut pas passer les chopons refait pas
l'histoire un soir d'élection comme ça
ça se passe comme ça tu un sondage il
prenait tout les engagements qu'ils
avaient pris
marie-guite dufay et de loin c'était une
des régions les mieux gérées ça c'est la
première des choses
la seconde chose ensuite quand il ya la
possibilité et je remercie manuel vals
je remercie jean christophe cambadélis
d'avoir retiré nos listes quand il y
avait un danger du front national
aujourd'hui on ne parlerait pas d'aucune
région qui a basculé au front national
si on n'avait pas eu cette
responsabilité à madame monté côté cela
à côté cela dit je remarque que nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas fait du tout le même
choix
et s'il avait été à notre place il y
aurait certainement aujourd'hui il y
aurait certainement d'ailleurs c'est
très bon et après souffrent les jeunes
va ce film tel qu'est ce que vous
vouliez dire moi l'analyse que je porte
sur ses résultats ce soir c'est que le
front national évidemment été la seule
force par rapport au système umts et si
les socialistes l'ont emporté ce soir
c'est tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
fait marcher leurs réseaux dans les
grandes villes
on a regardé les listes d'émargement on
a passé les coups de fil on a fait faire
des procurations ils ont une
organisation dans ces grandes villes qui
leur a permis de faire de faire la
différence ce soit ordonner sa cible
avait pas on n'est pas à la tête de
besançon ou à la tête de dijon mais je
tiens à dire que la progression du front
national est constante et que nous
sommes durablement ancré dans le paysage
parce que contrairement les zones
rurales ne nous ont pas lâchés du tout
au contraire elles ont progressé nous
ont fait progresser regarder les
résultats dans l'yonne regarder les
résultats en haute saône dans le
département de du doubs nous sommes
toujours deuxièmes dans le département
du doubs nous sommes premiers dans le
territoire de belfort
moi ce que je remarque c'est que voilà
ce n'est pas un vote d'exaspération je
le redis c'est un véritable vote
d'adhésion et vous
parliez tout à l'heure du bilan de
madame du fait mais monsieur bourquin
les électeurs se sont aussi prononcés
pour sanctionner pour vous envoyer un
message très clair ils ne veulent plus
de la gouvernance des gouvernements ump
s en france ils ont choisi au moins pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux au moins
trois cent soixante seize mille ils
veulent un véritable changement à
l'incarner dans le fond d'asile genevard
par rapport à nicolas sarkozy dont
parlait martial burqa nicolas sarkozy
manque son retour en politique de dieu
m'a laissé là c'est mon droit
je voudrais dire à madame ont-elles qui
évidemment utilise l'expression convenue
du mps que la position des républicains
qui a été quasi unanime a été de dire ni
front national ni couche et au fond ça
clarifier le débat mais je trouve que
c'est un débat pour le coup politicien
moi ce que je voudrais retenir de ces
élections c'est que tout de même ses
résultats interpellent l'ensemble de la
classe politique et je ne crois pas qu
on aille très loin en diabolisant en
caricaturant les uns ou les autres
je pense qu'il y a là des résultats qui
interpelle la droite parce qu'une partie
de son électorat n'a pas trouvé de
réponses ou difficultés et inquiétudes
qui sont les siennes mais ça interpelle
aussi la gauche qui est lourdement
sanctionné malgré tout parce qu'elle
fait de petits scores pour la politique
qu'elle conduit au niveau national qui
est un véritable désastre
à bien des égards et je pense que ce qui
s'est exprimé dans cette élection c'est
une grande inquiétude sur le plan
économique sur le plan identitaire sur
le plan sécuritaire et cette inquiétude
là nous avons l'impérieux devoir d'y
répondre
et dès ce soir les républicains ont
affirmé qu'ils entendaient travailler à
apporter des réponses crédibles ou juste
question que se posent les nos
concitoyens marcel voka et les lampes
aux remises en cause du parti
alice évidemment qu après ce que
visiblement tous les socialistes ne sont
pas forcément d'accord certains font un
peu trier je suis en soit j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure une nouvelle phase le
premier ministre dire qu'ils ne qu'on ne
pouvait pas faire l'impasse sur le
premier tour
faire l'impasse sur la grande inquiétude
sur les questions parfois la
désespérance sociale
j'ai entendu christophe canalis demander
des inflexions concernant dans
différents domaines et donc le débat
s'engage ce serait irresponsable de ne
pas voir un débat j'avais vraiment du
tout je ne suis la va-vite et reese et
je ne suis pas de la façon dont je ne
suis pas du tout madame genevard quand
elle dit on va pas diaboliser le front
national vous l'avez dit les a et les 90
les rouages et on vise à aider on a un
débat entre nous on est adversaire là
sont des ennemis de la démocratie et de
la république et ça sera jamais je pense
qu'on ne transige pas ces questions
alors j'ai vu que tu fais tu es une
vraie inflexion dans ce domaine c'est
une drôle d'inflexion moi je le suis
mais après cette inflexion là pour moi
le front national est un ennemi de la
république et de la démocratie
et je peux vous dire qu'après le premier
tour effectivement les réseaux
fonctionné c'était l'hommage du vice à
la vertu mais c'est la démocratie voilà
chez un journal merci mais d'affaires
appel aux électeurs mais soldats merci
monsieur
donc retour à dijon mot studio de dix
jours merci beaucoup catherine avec un
sujet arnaud justement bien sûr les
militants qui ont suivi et le françois
sauvadet et françois sauvadet qui arrive
donc le deuxième avec 32 9% des voix et
25 sièges ce soir au conseil régional de
la future bourgogne franche comté nous
avons suivi la journée de françois
sauvadet sébastien qui est roux et
christophe gaillard à l'annoncé des
résultats
les soutiens de françois sauvadet font
grise mine un demi point sépare le
candidat de l'union de la droite de
marie-guite dufay à 20 heures malgré
cette défaite annoncée
les militants garde espoir
on a des estimations car évoquant good
l'erreur de l'agglo sont pas terminés
donc tous les espoirs sont permis
autre mauvaise surprise le front
national qui a gagné des voix
supplémentaires
au deuxième tour on attaque extrêmement
fort en mort étrange coûté sa
circulation et je pense qu'il faudra
effectivement réfléchir à un moyen
qu'ils ont trouvé pour lutter contre ce
phénomène
au fil des minutes les résultats tombent
la droite distancé par marie-guite dufay
ne remportera pas la région de bourgogne
franche comté le maire de beaune est
amère mais reste fair play pourquoi on a
des scores aussi important sur d'autres
régions ce que ya eu un désistement d'un
désistement d'un peu mieux je me mets à
la place des socialistes s'ils après
tout on a eu raison
c'est comme ça qu'on gagne région et
saint paul ii c'est tout s'éclaire notre
assise et que le meilleur gagne
si marié du fait que ce soir on l'a
félicité 21h30 françois sauvadet
retrouve en face à ses militants
celui qui était encore favori il ya un
mois doit reconnaître sa défaite
j'assume l'entière responsabilité de
cette campagne
ils ont perdu peu nous avons perdu de
demain nous allons nous remettre au
travail ensemble au service de la côte
d'or je participe aux travaux du conseil
régional je les dis je démissionnerais
mon mandat parlementaire je les annonces
et je respecterai mes engagements je
veux dire à tous ceux qui m'ont fait
confiance que nous coûte vignerons de
nous battre pendant ces six années
une défaite lourde à digérer pour les
républicains et lui dit
pour les militants la nuit sera
difficile nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau de nouveaux indices
invitée catherine à vendresse bonjour
vous venez d'être élu sur la liste de
françois sauvadet pour la côte-d'or côté
maxime thibeault qui conduisait la liste
debout la france au premier tour dans
soir à tous les deux merci de nous
retrouver une question peut-être
catherine vandriesse qu'effectivement la
nuit va être difficile oui la lutte va
être difficile mais je vous écoute
depuis quelques minutes et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ait une analyse un
petit peu plus sophistiquée quand même
dans les résultats électoraux parce
qu'on a un vote les complexes
alors si je fais que de la politique
politicienne je dis à ma voisine de
droite
manas du fait qu'aujourd'hui près de
façon le 5 % des électeurs n'ont pas
soutenu finalement les projets qu'elle
avait bunny et le programme qu'elle
conduisait ça c'est une réalité concrète
oui mais c'est quand même une réalité
particulière dans un phénomène de
triangulaires il faut quand même le
rappeler la deuxième position sur le
front national moi j'ai deux approches
relativement différente
d'abord on peut pas avoir une position
simplement caricatural sur le vote front
national rural et front national urbain
même si effectivement les scores le 10
mai je vous donne un exemple vous allez
dire qu'il est partisan mais c'est un
exemple concret vous savez que la
circonscription la plus rurale de france
est la 4ème circonscription de côte-d'or
c'est celle de françois sauvadet c'est
la plus rurale de france et il est en
tête largement sur cette conception donc
le positionnement simplement une analyse
le monde rural s'oppose au nombre des
villes par un vote front il existe c'est
vrai mais lorsqu'on est élu territoire
avec des scores parce que je rappelle
quand même que nous arrivons en tête
en côte-d'or largement eh bien on se
rend compte qu'il ya aussi des élus de
terrain qui permettent d'endiguer la
montée du front national
la deuxième position sur le front
national ce qui m'inquiète parce qu'on
n'en parle pas et je pense qu'on va
avoir les détails dans les heures à
venir
c'est le vote des jeunes en faveur du
front national ça c'est un vrai sujet de
société
c'est un vrai sujet pour lequel nous
élus nous avons une responsabilité et il
faut que dans les mois et les années à
venir sur les mandats qui vont arriver
quel qu'il soit nous essayons aussi de
trouver une réponse à ces problèmes que
nous n'avons pas trouvé dans l'eau parti
démocratique républicain madame
vandriesse est ce qu'il ya un problème
avec la franche comté à droite parce que
françois sauvadet et 1er en bourgogne ce
soir et les troisièmes en franche comté
on quand on a fait le cumul m'a bien
comptés mais c'est ça la vérité est ce
que pourquoi ça n'a pas marché en
franche comté
c'est compliqué vous avez réponse l'a
immédiatement d'abord finalement je suis
ce que vous m'apprenez les résultats on
sort des bureaux de vote
je suis plutôt satisfaite finalement du
score en bourgogne sur la franche comté
il ya deux particularités alors vous
savez que la franche comté a aussi
historiquement un positionnement par
rapport à la bourgogne for ever aux
francs comtois
non je ne pense pas que françois
sauvadet fait port franc comtois parce
que l'histoire d'abord d'abord je vais
vous dire quelque chose
j'aime beaucoup les francs comtois rond
s'est rencontré dans le cadre de cette
élection
parce qu'ils ont ce sens pratique du
terroir dont on a besoin aussi je suis
chef d'entreprise vous le savez je suis
élu par ailleurs et on a besoin en
france de retrouver des élus pragmatique
capable d'évaluer c'est ce qu'on a
beaucoup reproché à la gauche à la
région puisque je suis un concert
régionale sortante
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
qui est une obligation aujourd'hui mais
qui est une obligation difficile à faire
exécuter dans des exécutifs de gauche
alors sur la franche comté
françois sauvadet a passé beaucoup de
temps en campagne en franche comté
si vous faites le grattage ça n'a pas
suffi vous avez raison mais c'est à cet
entre-deux stratégique politique voulue
parce que évidemment d'abord par nature
il était moins connu en franche comté ce
que très logique
et puis c'est un territoire qui est très
différent du nôtre on est quand même sur
des régions qui ont des situations pas
vrai les candidates franc comtoise font
font des scores plus honorable en
bourgogne mais dans les analyses que
vous avez fait tout à l'heure puisque je
les ai entendus sur le plateau de
besançon je pense qu'il ya aussi une
analyse très politique politicienne
les résultats aujourd'hui 10 score très
serré que nous avons c'est en grande
partie aussi par l'appareil politique du
parti socialiste qui s'est
particulièrement mobilisé à dijon et à
besançon qui fait qu'aussi la politique
politicienne a repris ses droits
saoulé ce qu'on reproche aujourd'hui moi
ma grande déception c'est évidemment le
résultat mais la vraie grande déception
c'est que depuis le 13 novembre
il n'y a pas eu débat sur la
problématique des élections régionales
et des enjeux de la région
voilà et et là dessus nous a et nous
avons été les seuls
très honnêtement organiser des réunions
publiques à être présent sur quatre ans
et la droite nationale
je veux dire c'est que le débat
aujourd'hui
il a aussi une connotation nationale
vous le savez très bien dans les
résultats des élections aujourd'hui
bien entendu on serait malhonnête de ne
pas le reconnaître c'est que c'est ce
que je regrette d'ailleurs parce que il
y avait des vrais enjeux de demain mais
demain c'est lundi c'est demain matin on
est à 1500 vous parliez tout à l'heure
des jeunes apprentis hambourg est
franche comté depuis trois ans trois
mille cinq cents apprentis ses 3500
jeunes qui ne trouvent pas de treuils ya
j'ai fait passer la loi est passée les
42000 chaud mais les menteurs personne
n'en parle
vous parlais tout à l'heure des jeunes
qui y voter fn jeu j'aimerais demander à
un jeune à côté de vous s'il a voté fn
maxime thibeault puisque je rappelle
vous étiez tête de liste régionale de
debout la france un peu plus de 5% des
voix au premier tour 4e de ceux de ce
scrutin
vous n'aviez pas donné de consigne de
vote tout à fait vous aviez juste
précisé que vous étiez socialiste est ce
qu'on est ce que c'est parce que vous
avez voté aujourd'hui
ben non je montre mon vote et dans le
secret de l'isoloir et je ne le dirai
pas mais là où où c'est vrai c'est que
les jeunes mais ne croient plus aux
partis politiques y croit plus au ps une
croix pur l'ump dont soit ils se
mobilisent pas soit ils viennent crier
dans les urnes et moi je ne veux pas
diaboliser le front national ce soir
si on veut battre le front national
demain il faut refaire un projet et je
pense aujourd'hui que vous parties sont
départis d'écurie qui défendent des
hommes mais qui ne défendent pas des
idées et moi mon objectif et c est l
idée du premier tour c'était défendre
des projets 6 à 24 ans je m'engage en
politique c'est parce que je ne crois
plus en la classe politique actuelle est
que mon objectif et les saintes c'est de
défendre un projet au niveau de la
région et demain au niveau de l'état
voilà mais vous ne pourrez pas le faire
tout seul
mais on le fait que vous aurez les
produits d'avoir de ne pas avoir discuté
avec la ligue mais c'était pas à moi
d'appeler monsieur sauvadet monsieur
sauvadet ne m'a pas appelé je suis
républicain j'aurais pu discuter après
il y avait des conditions c'était de
garantir l'indépendance de mon mouvement
et surtout un projet parce que moi je
suis pas là pour me placer nous avons
des projets politiques oui vous avez
plus en commun avec le fn qui avait que
lui dit aujourd'hui la souveraineté la
presse le rapport à l'or il
très certain que je crois en la
souveraineté nationale pour autant je ne
crois pas que le plan le pen pourra
gouverner la france demain parce que les
français n'en veulent pas et puis je
pense très sincèrement que son plan
interne le front national a des idées
très proches du communisme en termes de
politique économique
mais il est certain que je pense qu'il
faut construire une alternative
politique au système politique que les
français ne veulent plus avant le ps et
l'ump et au front national que les
français ne veulent pas et aujourd'hui
quand une grande majorité des français
qui attendent autre chose et j'ai été
très content de la carne au premier tour
on va à présent passer le sujet le
reportage tourné par nos équipes qui ont
suivi sophie montel vous l'avez entendu
tout à l'heure la tête de lice pour le
front national le front national qui
arrive donc en troisième position de ces
élections régionales avec 32 4% des voix
un reportage tourné par justine sagot et
de nicole la marseillaise malgré la
défaite largement en tête au premier
tour le front national n'arrive qu'en
deuxième position derrière marie-guite
dufay
mais ce soir les militants refusent de
s'avouer vaincu plus de voix que le
coeur la dernière semaine alors plus de
gens qui ont voté pour nous même est
ouverte et le front national elle
reprend perd pas non progresse on
prendra notre ascension est irréversible
les forces ont tiré près cible à la
bataille de france à commencer en 2012
marine le pen
la vie aux efforts nous continuons sur
notre lancée sur notre progression
il n'y a plus de gauche il n'y a plus de
droite le fn davis avec un taux de
participation qui explosent en bourgogne
franche comté
les électeurs se sont mobilisés pour
faire barrage au font national arrivé
dans son qg de rang à 20h30
sophie montel garde le sourire quand on
continue et ne portait plus ou encore ce
soir on assiste très objectivement à une
victoire à la pyrrhus de la part du d'un
système que nous dénonçons le système
ump s madame buffet visiblement
l'emporterait d'une très courte tête par
rapport à mes shows sauvadet le front
national étant lui aussi ça se joue dans
un mouchoir de poche
sophie montel ne sera pas président de
la grande région bourgogne franche comté
mais pour elle la machine frontiste
commence à peine à se mettre en marche
quasiment 23 heures le rappel des
résultats définitifs en bourgogne
franche comté où marie guite dufay
arrive donc en tête avec 34 7% des voix
devant la liste à l'air udi de françois
sauvadet 32,9 et celle du front national
conduite par sophie montel avec 32,4
pour cent un dernier mot marais du duvet
une res on arrive au terme de cette
dernière émission vous allez être donc
la nouvelle présidente de la grande
région la nouvelle grande région de
bourgogne franche comté
qu'est ce que vous allez faire demain
tout simplement je vais mettre en
application les 110 propositions que
j'ai travaillé je veux travailler à une
bourgogne franche comté dans laquelle ye
du bonheur qu'il y ait une capacité à
vivre un vivre bien ensemble un jeu j'ai
mis en avant cette cette valeur et je
m'y engagerai à travers la culture à
travers le sport à travers le mouvement
associatif et puis je veux protéger de
protéger tous ceux qui souffrent il a
réglé
merci la soirée continue avec carole
gaessler et francis letellier france 3
point fr pour retrouver les résultats
et puis sinon évidemment demain bien sûr
9h50 dans la matinale avec justement le
résumé de cette soirée et pivot on
retrouve bien évidemment dans vos
journaux à midi et 19 points c'est une
très belle contrée